all right uh let's get to some questions
about
cam newton coming in at number 10.
obviously there's going to be some
strong feelings about that
marley
gusu on twitter asks if being a dual
threat quarterback is important enough
to have cam in the top ten why do all
the statues in the teens have jobs and
cam doesn't chris
well hey
that's a good question we've addressed
some of that certainly you know cam
newton
again he was a little unlucky with how
things played out in carolina i don't
know all the story there but certainly
karen
carolina releasing him as late as he did
teams already being set with the
quarterback situation mike we've
discussed this as we both know he's not
the kind of guy you want to come in and
be a backup quarterback he's scary he'll
divide the team you know like you said
in the first hour he's one of those guys
after the first practice player's going
to come off the field be like man did
you see some of those throws cam newton
today did you see when he broke out of
the pocket and started running and
through that 40-yard laser across the
other side of the field you know man you
know that that starts a quarterback
controversy that starts to divide in the
locker room so you know that's the
biggest reason he's not on the football
team right now and yes you know yeah
he's not the statue that brees and brady
are uh but they play a different style
of game and yeah they're more predicated
on eating a system around them right now
more than maybe cam newton would be
interesting question from bobble what if
the denver broncos broke cam newton in
super bowl 50 and remember how that game
ended there was that controversial play
where the ball was loose and some
thought cam didn't make enough of an
effort to try to recover and then after
the game during the press conference
they had curtains up separating the
various people who were talking chris
harris jr then with the broncos was
crowing loudly about what they did to
the panthers the panthers favor to win
the game cam newton stormed off any
credence to the idea that he's been a
different guy since that day
i i don't think so i don't i mean
you know was there some super bowl loss
hangover the next year yeah sure
certainly
but you know i still look at that game
and go hey the carolina panthers blew
that football game the carolina panthers
let down cam newton you know there was
no like law that they had to sit there
and and try to win a you know let cam
newton drop back seven step drops hold
the ball that long against von miller
and that defense you know so some of the
game planning was stupid mike think
don't forget about all the drop passes
carolina had in that game so certainly
not a great day but i was sitting there
in the stands that day going man i can
remember about three or four plays the
interception down the middle uh right
between two hands goes in the air
interception denver as they're going
into scoring position there was about
three other plays too but i don't think
that broke cam newton i think he's very
mentally strong and is a true competitor
and loves plan under the big lights
one more point before we take a break a
handful of people have asked a question
using some of the some of the words it
would only be in chris sims vocabulary
why am i stumping for colin kaepernick
to get a job
and not cam newton and let me just
address that briefly first of all we
have been stumping for cam newton to get
a job we have been claiming that the
panthers did him wrong by holding on to
his rights we've explained he's been a
victim of circumstance and we've talked
about why he's currently stuck in the
predicament he's in he should have a job
and i'd like to think he will have a job
but i don't believe there's been a
collective effort to shun
cam newton i believe that colin
kaepernick became a guy that the nfl
teams decided to stay away from it's not
some crazy conspiracy theory he filed a
collusion grievance against the nfl it
was settled reportedly between five and
ten million dollars i know per team
that's not much but it's not very often
the nfl writes a check to anybody to
resolve a legal case there was something
going on the mere fact that he's never
been offered an opportunity to even be a
backup for someone else shows that
there's something going on here beyond
whether or not he's good enough whether
or not he's up to snuff as the president
said so right i think they both should
be in the nfl
but i get more riled up about kaepernick
because my bs detector has been
screaming for the last three years chris
that they are doing this guy wrong
yeah no i that's exactly right and yeah
you know for those people who are
questioning that we've been banging the
table a lot that cam newton should be a
starting quarterback on the team we
banged the table before the draft the
chargers should should sign them you
know i was just in the first hour again
you know saying jacksonville i still
think they should sign them so yeah
you've been supportive but it is it's a
different scenario there's a lot of
different issues there between
kaepernick and cam newton that are not
apples to apples and uh you're right
kaepernick was black blackballed by the
nfl there's no other way to say that cam
newton is in a weird time of covid19
pandemic can't get a medical exam and
he's threatening because he's very
talented and all these teams have a
starting quarterback so that's that i
know we got to go to a commercial
i really wish that collusion grievance
wouldn't have settled i'd love to have
access to the deposition transcripts i'd
love to be able to dig in to all the
evidence that was compiled so i could
explain to people where the evidence is
because it's no one's going to admit it
no one's going to sit there and say oh
yes we black bottom it's circumstantial
evidence that you weave together through
aggressive questioning of people and you
expose the the inaccuracies and
inconsistencies in the various stories
to lead to the conclusion that there was
something going on hi i'm mike tarico
and thanks for watching make sure to hit
subscribe for the latest news and
highlights from nbc sports